do you think you've got the most
dedicated fan base
it feels that way yeah yeah the star
trek fans might have something to say
about that
and marvel as well of course
yeah well
[Music]
this can get competitive quickly yeah
just to see which how dark the dark side
you're on you never know with you which
how deeply into the darkness
shall we red is the coolest color of
lightsaber three two one
well there you are yeah i mean i could
really
i could be both sides of this line in
truth yeah yeah i was always blue you
were always blue
samuel jackson was purple obviously
perfectly and that was like something
that he he said i'll play the role if i
can have a purple lightsaber that's what
he told george
and he goes why isn't he got it i mean
you're not going to say no to sammy
jackson anyway we we went through a nice
collection of sabres yeah the
lightsabers that we used back in the in
the
prequels were
literally like met there was a certain
kind of alloy i don't know it was a
metal pole
yeah and they would bend like they we we
would fight and every take
we did in a fight what they would bend
you know because we were because it's
like full contact when you're really
we're really having to go to each other
and yeah they would be all warped at the
end of it they'd replace you with a new
saber it was that guy on set who just
had a hit a car on wheels
thomas yeah
that's right yeah and all he did was
make lightsabers and every take we'd be
handed a new one
and nowadays they're different they're
different now i sort of missed the old
ones to be honest they had a nice view
of them yeah
yeah they're real clash together it's
the good old days
lightsabers aren't where they used to be
darth vader is the best villain in movie
history three two one
well played yeah
i can't think of anyone else's yeah i
mean more villainy a villain than him i
strongly agree very scary to see him you
know i we i didn't work with darth vader
in episode one to three because he
wasn't you know
you weren't him yet but then in this
series that we've just made to see you
coming at me with that
it's like made me feel like i was seven
years old again like the fear that went
through me was genuine
i've never had that acting before where
you have like a
actual like
fear moment you know but i
i felt that when when i turned around
and there you were like like
seven feet tall with the helmet and
it had been
uh
17 18 years since since i last put it on
and
um
what an experience i mean you know uh
it's a it's it's an incredible costume
yeah
do you feel evil in it
you can't help not but i mean it really
informs the way you feel uh
yeah you do
motorbikes are the best form of travel
three two one
yeah yeah
i'm going with agree because
i don't really ride motorbikes but i
love dirt bikes yeah the first time i
was on a bike was actually with you
i don't know if you remember but but uh
in sydney actually here in london oh
yeah yeah when we when we first got to
london to do some of the uh additional
photography yeah you came and picked me
up at the hotel and went for a ride on
your bike oh yeah uh
you were fast
i was holding on for dear life
i love it it was amazing yeah yeah my
dad was a
there was a charity organization in my
little town of creif and my dad was the
chairman of this charity organization
one year kids would write in and one of
this little kid wanted to ride a
motorbike so my dad organized for his
friend to bring a little 50cc motorbike
like one of those tiny little honda ones
to a field and this little kid got to
ride around and i was there
and after this kid rode around my dad
said do you want a go and i went okay
so i got on this
motorbike and it was tiny and i was
quite tiny and it was just a twist and
go no gears and i
took off on it and i i like my life
changed you know i just i couldn't
believe that this turned into this and i
still feel a bit like that today like
when i get on a bike and i write
somewhere i still feel like
are they really letting me do this like
i'm a real is this it's so good it
should be illegal or something you know
you have that feeling
so um i've never gotten over it and
that's still my favorite way to get
around i love it
the prequels were underrated three two
one
i mean by not by the not by the people
that love the that
so we made them for in fact yeah
underrated at the time at the time yeah
and by the way
i feel like now though just just needed
a little bit of time you know to sort of
ferment in our popular culture yeah yeah
but i think they were appreciated at the
time by the by the generation we made
them for if you like it's just that that
took there was no social media then
there was no that we didn't hear their
voice as much as
as you would do nowadays you know with a
film that coming out now you there's no
question what people think about it
because you can see it on social media
and
the audience's voice is much louder now
if you like um and at the time
basically the reaction was driven by the
critics who
decided they weren't as good as the
original film or
and george always had a
you know he always had a very strong
idea to make them to make them different
kinds of movies he wasn't he didn't set
out to remake what he'd done in the 70s
he wanted to try to tell some uh
to set those films up if you like but
also to make them feel different which
which they do the star wars universe is
the best cinematic universe
three
two one
yeah i think it's a testament that we
love that there's so many different
stories being told within it now
because we like that world you know
george created something that we
can escape into and i think that's why
people love it so i mean there's lots of
reasons why people love it i think but
the fact that we can tell different
stories from different timelines yeah
with characters from the original
trilogy or not you know
and that's really been so fun to watch
it just continue to grow and expand yeah
i i love it yeah me too i love it yeah
do you think you've got the most
dedicated fan base
it feels that way yeah yeah the star
trek fans might have something to say
about that
will ignite a war yeah
people beating each other up in cinema
cues around the world
and marvel as well of course
yeah well
pineapple on pizza is delicious three
two one
it depends
i feel like pineapple
with like
i've had pineapple with jalapeno on the
pizza okay and it's a great combination
okay it was actually jet george george's
son that told me about yeah you gotta
put some jalapeno with with the
with the pineapple wow and what would
you just have the pineapple
on its own when i was young yeah yeah
yeah really i grew up in canada listen
don't blame the canadians
for your own strange tastes you know
i don't know i i wouldn't
i don't think i've ever ordered i'll
make you pizza one time you'll be on
this side soon okay yeah
you're gonna pull me over to the
employee order the agrees i agree
my favorite pizza is pepperoni with
anchovies
because i just must have a real salty
taste you know
but don't i don't know that i've ever
ordered a pizza with
pineapple of course i've had i've picked
a slice up from somewhere that's got
pineapple on it but it's not something i
would ever think to order
obi-wan's jedi mullet is the worst
hairstyle in cinema history three two
wow no strongly we can't bring on that
one yeah no no no no no no you rock that
mole no very well
at the time
probably i didn't think it was a
i might have gone over here
but now no i think it's it's like part
of this it's like it's iconic yeah
that's an iconic mallet yeah it's quite
a mullet though isn't it really it's
very bg's i think it's a sort of bg's
haircut more than anything bg jedi
did you like the little was it the plait
that you had coming down for another one
the padawan braid yeah i i did like that
me too
but mainly because you made it look so
cool in episode one i was like i get one
of those now yeah yeah it's an
interesting idea isn't it that is i've
met i've met people who have one who
have their own padawan parade because of
that yeah and they're also what's
forgotten is that you have the little
the thing in the thing on the back as
well which so that self had forgotten
about you had to grow your hair to so
that they could attach it and the rest
of it was very short so if you weren't
yeah if you weren't filming
your hair looked very odd yeah because
you had a long bit right here in a long
bit right here and everything else was
very short yeah i remember that first
thing in the morning but just having it
sort of glued in yeah you know
i kept a couple of them yeah yeah what's
funny is that they is that um you see
them up for auction every now and again
somebody sells one and like there was
only one
like there was a new one every day it
wasn't the same one
people are selling them like the jedi
brain
it's great to be working again with the
person opposite me three two one strong
i'm going all the way all the way over
here absolutely yeah that's just the
coolest thing
i mean
we became so close when we were doing
the prequels and just to get to come
back and
you know yeah do this again just to get
to sit here and and do this is
such a trip
it's just totally like picking up where
we left off i mean when we were on set
together
shooting for this tv series it felt like
the last 17 years didn't happen it was
very odd you didn't look uh like that's
how i felt about a day older like it was
so bizarre
yeah
i would trust tom holland with a spoiler
three two one
you would pay it up a lot during the
avengers so i was diving on grenades
left right center i begin to think now
he just does it so that i can be seen as
a babysitter yes